- Good afternoon, President Salovey,
Marta Moret, colleagues, and friends,
and welcome to the Tanner
Lecture on Human Values,
hosted by the Whitney Humanities Center.
My name is Alice Kaplan and
I'm director of the Whitney.
One of the privileges and
pleasures at the Whitney
is to advise the president
on the selection of Tanner lecturers.
This year, we've had the
exceptional opportunity
to invite a speaker working in the field
of artificial intelligence.
Fei-Fei Li is an international leader
in establishing a human-centered framework
for artificial intelligence in research,
education, practice, and policy.
Her visit to Yale is especially meaningful
for us at the Whitney, of course,
because it's our first Tanner
Lecture since the pandemic
and our first here in the
humanities quadrangle,
but also because it's
allowed us to reach deep
into our mission, to blend ways of knowing
as we've made contact with
a community of scholars
working in artificial intelligence
and related fields across the campus.
We've said to many of you that we are new
to the neighborhood of
artificial intelligence
and delighted to be here.
I'm especially grateful
to our Dean of the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences, Tamar Gendler,
to Gary Tomlinson, former Whitney Director
and Sterling Professor
of Music and Humanities,
and to Alan Gerber, Sterling
Professor of Political Science,
Director of the Institution for Social
and Public Policy Studies,
Professor of Economics
and Statistics and Data Science
for their knowledge and their support
in planning this event.
Before we begin, let me say a few words
about the Tanner Lectures on Human Values,
which were established
by the American scholar,
industrialist, and
philanthropist Obert Clark Tanner
and his wife, Grace Tanner.
Educated at the University of
Utah, Stanford, and Harvard,
Obert Tanner went on to
become a New Testament scholar
and professor at the University of Utah,
but that is not the whole story.
In order to pay for his education,
he founded a jewelry company
while still an undergraduate.
His company, O.C. Tanner,
which manufactures
employee recognition awards
and seeks to improve workplace cultures
through personalized employee recognition,
became an extraordinary success,
and it is on this base that Grace
and Obert Tanner's philanthropy was built.
Yale is one of a number
of universities in the US,
the UK, and beyond to
sponsor Tanner Lectures.
Appointment as a Tanner
lecturer is a recognition
of uncommon achievement
and outstanding ability
in the field of human values.
The lecturers come from many
fields and walks of life,
philosophy, religion,
and the other humanities,
the sciences, the creative
arts, the learned professions,
or, indeed, from leadership
in public or private affairs.
The lectureships are
international and intercultural
and are meant to transcend
ethnic, national,
religious, and ideological distinctions.
As I noted earlier, at Yale,
Tanner lecturers are
selected by the president
and consultation with the director
and the executive committee
of the Whitney Humanities Center.
We are thrilled, though
not at all surprised,
by this big turnout.
Yale is obviously delighted
that President Salovey invited Fei-Fei Li,
Sequoia Professor of Computer Science
at Stanford University
and Denning Co-Director
of the Stanford Institute
for Human-Centered AI.
You'll hear more about
Professor Li's achievements
and the impact of her work in a moment.
Please note that there will be no question
and answer period following the lecture.
The video recording will be posted
on the Yale YouTube
channel in the coming days,
and we invite you to check
the Whitney Humanity Center website
and subscribe to our weekly email
at subscribe.yale.edu for updates.
Now it is my pleasure to welcome
to the podium Professor Marvin Chun,
Richard M. Colgate Professor of Psychology
and Professor of Neuroscience.
Marvin, it's such a pleasure
after having worked with you
in your capacity as dean of the college
to welcome you today as
a leader in the study
of brain imaging and
artificial intelligence.
(audience applauding)
- Good afternoon, everyone.
Dr. Fei-Fei Li is one
of the most important
and influential researchers
in the entire history
of artificial intelligence.
If you enjoy the ability
to use verbal labels
to search through your
library of thousands of photos
or trust your Tesla to
maintain its lane and speed
as it races along with
other cars down a highway,
then you owe much to Dr. Li.
An AI system is only as good
as the data used to train it,
and amongst her many accomplishments,
she is responsible for
developing ImageNet,
a labeled database of images
that enabled revolutionary advances
in computer vision over
the past 10 to 15 years.
Even though I'm not a computer scientist,
I'm deeply honored to
have this opportunity
to introduce Dr. Li because
of our shared background
in cognitive neuroscience,
especially scene perception
and categorization,
a topic to which Dr. Li has
made pioneering contributions,
even before developing ImageNet.
Her broad research interests
span cognitively inspired AI,
machine learning, deep learning,
computer vision, and AI plus healthcare,
especially ambient intelligence systems
for healthcare delivery.
Dr. Li has published more
than 200 scientific articles
in top-tier journals and
conference proceedings.
Even more impressive is
her measurable impact
with a total of over 181,000 citations.
Her work attracts more
attention in one year
than most researchers gain
over their entire careers.
Not surprisingly, she has been recognized
with countless honors and awards,
including election to the
National Academy of Engineering,
the National Academy of Medicine,
and the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences.
I not only admire her
accomplishments in research
but her contributions to society.
She's a national leading voice
for advocating diversity in STEM and AI.
After serving as a director
of Stanford's AI Lab,
she took a sabbatical
from Stanford to serve
as the vice president at
Google and as Chief Scientist
of AI/Machine Learning at Google Cloud.
Now, Professor Li is the Co-Director
of Stanford Human-Centered AI Institute,
and beyond campus, she is
co-founder and chairperson
of the national nonprofit AI for All,
aimed at increasing inclusion
and diversity in AI education.
Recognized in 2016 by
the Carnegie Foundation
as one of the Great Immigrants:
The Pride of America,
if you consider other past
honorees on this list,
I can describe Dr. Li to
be like the Albert Einstein
or the Yo-Yo Ma of
artificial intelligence.
We are excited to hear her
speak to us about "What We See
and What We Value: AI
with a Human Perspective."
Please join me in welcoming
this year's Whitney Humanities
Center Tanner Lecturer
on Human Values, Dr. Fei-Fei Li.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you. It's quite
an honor to be here.
I really want to thank President Salovey
and the Whitney Humanities
Center for quite an honor.
Of course, I cannot pass the opportunity
to also honor another
incredible computer scientist
who came out of Yale.
That is Dr. Grace Hopper.
So for all of us, especially women,
working in computer science,
even after almost 90 years,
we still are following her footsteps
and trying to live up to
the incredible leadership
and trailblazing careers
she has established
for all the women in computer science,
and that journey has been
long and will still continue.
We haven't get to where
she probably envisioned
for all of us, but it's
quite an honor to be back
to the alma mater of Dr. Grace Hopper.
So I'm here to really share with you
some of my own work in the field of AI,
and I have to confess, as a
scientist and technologist,
when I enter this incredibly exciting
but not really new field
in AI two-plus decades ago,
it would not have been my wildest dream
that how profound this field has become
to the daily lives of
our collective humanity
and our society.
So I really cherish this moment
to share with you what we have learned
but really hope to engage
in a productive conversation with you.
I understand there will be a
conversation tomorrow as well
and hope to meet some of
you after the lecture.
So thank you so much.
I'll begin my talk.
As Alice has said,
the topic of my talk today is "What We See
and What We Value: AI
with a Human Perspective."
I'm going to take you back in history,
a little bit back in history,
540 million years ago.
(laughs) Just a little while back.
Life on Earth was very different.
It was all underwater.
Animals live in the
primordial soup of the ocean,
and frankly, there aren't that
many animals in the world.
And life was very chill.
They float around.
(audience chuckling)
And then something really
remarkable happened.
It was a mystery.
In what geologically consider
a very short period of time,
10 million years, between
540 million years ago
to 530 million years ago,
fossil studies have told us
the number of animal
species just exploded.
What happened?
There were many theories,
from climate change to
the chemical composition
of the ocean water and all this.
But there is one influential conjecture
that has captured the attention,
and this was put forth
by a Australian zoologist
called Andrew Parker.
By studying fossils,
he conjectured that
the Cambrian Explosion,
by the way, that's what
the period was called
with the animal speciation,
Cambrian Explosion
or Big Bang of Evolution, actually,
the Cambrian Explosion is triggered
by the sudden evolution of vision,
which set off an evolutionary arms race
where animals either evolved or died.
So vision, the onset of
vision and perception,
was one of the driving forces
of the evolution of animal species.
Furthermore, it's a driving force
of the evolution of the nervous system,
eventually leading up to very
intelligent animals like us.
In fact, today on Earth, most,
the majority of the animals
uses visual perception
as a major sensory system
to guide its survival
and thriving of the species.
And for us humans, we're
very much visual animals.
Our visual intelligence
gets us to communicate
with each other, to work,
to navigate the world,
to interact with the world,
to entertain ourselves,
and it's hard to believe
that we can live without much
of the visual intelligence.
In the meantime,
the field of intelligence
also started to evolve
in addition to what natural evolution is
in the field of computer science.
AI compared to evolution is a
very, very, very young field.
Most people say it's about 60 years.
But the history of computer vision
and the history of AI
is very much entangled.
Just at the very dawn of AI,
back around 60 years ago,
there was a very ambitious
MIT summer project,
and the MIT summer project
proposed by this professor says,
"We'll use our summer workers,"
and I suppose they had some smart ones,
"effectively to construct
a significant part
of a visual system or a
artificial visual system
within one summer."
Well, that didn't quite happen,
but the urban legend goes
that this is the beginning
of the field of computer vision,
that someone or a collection
of pioneering computer
scientists had to believe
that one day, we can create a
artificial intelligence system
with the kind of visual
intelligence that humans enjoy.
Fast forward to the second decade
or actually the third
decade of 21st century.
Vision has come a long way.
Just as Marvin was mentioning
about self-driving cars
or visual driving assistance
to image classification
to the incredible work
recently by generative arts,
vision has not only become a blossoming,
a vibrant academic discipline,
but it also has become a driving force
in commercialization and industry.
So the rest of the talk is
really to share with you
my own journey and
perspective about my field.
Where have we come from
and where are we heading?
And also, what are the human lessons
that we have learned along the way
of developing computer vision?
So one thing that's been really fun
to hear about this
audience is that you come
from all walks of discipline and areas,
and I'm not going to assume
everybody's a computer scientist
or a student of AI,
so let me just give a
very simple definition,
because a lot of you probably
hear the words like AI,
machine learning, deep
learning, computer vision, NLP.
What are these things?
Well, here's a cheat sheet.
(audience chuckling)
I'm not going to go over
everything and I won't quiz you,
but let's just get some basic definitions.
Artificial intelligence, AI,
is actually a term coined
by computer scientist
and Stanford's Emeritus
Professor John McCarthy.
Back in the 1950s, early '60s,
he described this field as the science
and engineering of making
intelligent machines.
Nature took 540 million years.
Let's see how long that
would take humanity
to create a silicon-based
intelligent machine.
And within the field of
artificial intelligence,
especially as it grows,
you start to see areas
of disciplines emerge,
such as field of computer vision,
field of natural language processing,
speech recognition,
and robotics and so on,
and there are more and more newer fields
within artificial intelligence
or related to artificial intelligence.
Okay.
And you also hear terms
like machine learning and deep learning.
What are these things?
Well, consider machine learning
the mathematical language
of doing today's AI.
In fact, there are other
mathematical languages
have been developed in the history of AI,
but for the purpose of this talk,
machine learning is a
relatively young discipline
in computer science that
combines statistics,
apply math, and even inspired
by neuroscience and psychology
and all this in terms of
creating computer programs
based on statistical
models to achieve the goals
of different kinds of AI tasks.
And within machine learning,
the latest revolution is based on a family
of algorithms called neural networks.
And we'll get to that a little more later,
but you hear neural networks a lot
probably on news these days,
and also there is a better name now
or less nerdy name for neural network,
which is called deep learning.
So these are the words
you will hear from me.
Okay, so let's get to the talk.
So I want to share with you three parts
of the work we have done,
and the first one is building
AI to see what humans see.
First of all, let's just accept this.
Humans are incredible visual
animals, and we can see a lot.
In fact, our visual system is very robust.
This is a seminal study by Molly Potter
back in the 1970s with her colleagues
to show you that...
She show you a video and consider you
a human subject in her
lab, and nod your head
if you see a person in one of the frames.
Okay, I see all.
Good. You have good visual systems.
We get that out of the way, and...
But take a moment to reflect
how remarkable this is.
Every frame here is only on the screen
for a hundred millisecond,
refreshed at 10 hertz frequency.
And other than, say, me
telling you to detect a person,
you don't know what the person looks like,
the gesture of the person,
where in the frame it is,
what kind of clothes it's wearing.
You don't know if this is
a man, woman, or anything.
Yet, your visual system is really quick
at recognizing and detecting this object.
Furthermore, by the turn of the century,
shortly before the turn of the century,
neurophysiologists like Simon Thorpe
and his colleagues have also put a speed
of processing of our
remarkable visual system
when categorizing complex natural scenes.
The experiment he did
is to put human subject
in front of computers and flash them
with complex photos of
animals or non-animals.
Here are some examples.
And the task of the human is to just say
"Yes, I see an animal" or
"I don't see an animal."
Mind you, these are really
complex real-life pictures.
You don't know which kind of
animal is going to come up.
You don't know what the distractor
pictures are going to be.
And in the meantime,
he is measuring your
brain wave through EEG.
And as early as 150 millisecond
after the onset of the visual stimuli,
he sees a differential
signal in human brain
that tells you the difference
between an animal picture
and a non-animal picture.
Considering our wetware
here is a lot slower
than transistors, this is
a remarkable achievement
in terms of the fleeting speed
that our visual processing is.
In addition to temporal capabilities,
we also find neural
correlates, areas in the brain,
that are dedicated to object recognition,
such as faces or places
or even body parts.
This is a concurrent set of studies
during the turn of the century
showing us these kind of brain areas.
So all this is to show you
that there's something remarkable
about our human visual brain,
and one of the most remarkable
thing is our ability
to do object recognition
or to categorize objects.
In fact, we believe, and
cognitive neuroscientists
and vision psychologists believe,
object recognition is a
fundamental building block
of visual intelligence.
And for those of us who work in AI,
especially trying to make machines see,
this has become a north star.
It's a important ability we need
to endow the machines with.
So formally speaking,
the task of object recognition
is to show, let's say,
an agent, whether it's
a a brain or a computer,
a picture of an object,
and the agent is capable
of output the category of
what this picture contains,
in this case, a very cute
Australian animal, a wombat.
You might wonder how hard is
it because you can all do it.
Well, mathematically speaking,
any 3D object in the world
can render infinite number
of pictures in a 2D frame,
whether it's a camera
frame or your retina,
because of the infinite
possibilities of lighting,
appearance differences,
background clutter, occlusion,
self-occlusion, camera viewing angles.
So this is a hard task,
and now evolution has solved it for us.
Let's see how we solve it in computers.
At this point, I'm going to bring you
to the last lesson
or diversion of machine
learning and AI today.
It's this concept of generalization.
So for the rest of the talk,
no matter what project I'm talking about,
as long as I'm talking about AI,
mathematically, the goal of AI
and developing a AI algorithm
is to solve the problem of generalization.
What is the problem of generalization?
The generalization is the following.
When we develop an algorithm or a system
that is capable of doing something,
in this case, recognizing
objects or wombat pictures,
our goal is actually not
to train the algorithm
so that the training
error goes to minimal.
That's a little counterintuitive
because of course
you want the training error
to go to minimal, right?
That's why you send your kids to school.
But your kids will also get out of school
and go to the real world,
so what you really want is,
once the algorithm encounter a case,
an example that is not in training
but in testing or in generalization time,
you want the algorithm
still to be able to do well.
You want the testing error
or the generalization error
to be as small as possible.
In fact, the gap between the testing error
and the training error,
you want it to be as small as possible.
And that goal or that process
of making this happen is generalization.
And in AI or machine learning,
our mathematical goal
is always to achieve the
best possible generalization.
Okay, we got the nerd talk out of the way.
So let's continue with the
visual tasks we care about,
which is object recognition.
In the early days, back last century,
the pioneering computer
scientist have used,
there was very little compute,
there was practically no data,
and we know very little about
the mathematical models.
So pioneering scientists have designed
hand-designed features
and hand-designed models
to try to account
for how to recognize complex objects.
And it was a beautiful...
It was a bunch of beautiful
conceptual theories,
but it didn't go very far in
real-world generalization.
Around the turn of 20th to 21st century,
a new tool emerged,
and that fundamentally
changed many areas of AI,
including computer vision,
and that's the tool
of machine learning or
statistical modeling.
So in this time, we start to
see a lot of interesting work
of using hand-designed
features or patches of images
but start to use machine learning models
to learn the parameters of these features.
This might be a little over
the head for some of you
who are not in computer
science, but it doesn't matter.
All you need to know
is that we're starting
to move towards machine learning
and machine-learned
parameterization of models.
Something else important
happened during that time,
which is actually the
availability of data.
Internet start to happen,
and the field of AI and
computer vision start
to have available pictures
to train our algorithms on.
So in this seminal early work
by a group of European scientists,
they created this data
set called PASCAL VOC
so that the whole community
of computer vision field
can start working on the
object recognition problem
by using this data set
of a few thousand images
and 20 object classes.
That was also around the
time I graduated from PhD
and became an assistant professor,
and something really bugged me,
because while it's really cool,
we're working on this north star problem
of object recognition, but
we're working with 20 objects.
Cognitive psychologists have told us
humans have a remarkable ability
of recognizing object categories,
more than 30,000 object
categories by tender age of six.
So 20 versus 30,000,
it didn't fully compute.
So my students and I started
to examine the previous work
in color vision and object recognition.
I realized one of the biggest problem
we might be facing is not the
hand-design models per se.
It's actually the data we're training on.
So in a three-year effort,
my collaborators and my students
and I went a little crazy.
We downloaded the entire
internet we could get to
back in 2006, 2007.
More than a billion images we hand-curated
through a crowd engineering method.
15 meticulously cleaned
and labeled images...
Oh, sorry. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
15 million meticulously
curated, labeled images
across 22,000 object categories.
And that was the ImageNet project.
And ImageNet was born
with the ambition
that it will fuel computer vision
and machine learning algorithm
in a fundamentally,
qualitatively different way.
And to our, I wouldn't say surprise,
but we're very happy to
see that start to happen.
A particular family of
model that did really well
when there is a huge flood
and wealth of data available
is neural network models or algorithms,
especially in computer vision,
convolutional neural network.
Convolutional neural network is one
of the statistical models
developed since the last century,
and it's not a particularly
new set of algorithms.
The early onset of the
convolutional neural network history
began even in the '60s and '70s
and was further refined by people
like Jeff Hinton and Yann LeCun.
And for those of you not familiar
with this neural network model,
it is actually inspired
by the brain, in fact,
by the cat brain and the
Hubel and Wiesel study
on the cat visual system.
So the fundamental building block
of a neural network is a node,
a neuron-like node that takes input
from other nodes and sends output.
And not only they take inputs,
they also are layered hierarchically
so you can pass information
around in a efficient way.
So even 10 years ago,
with the availability of
ImageNet, we were making models,
neural network models as
large as millions of nodes
and hundreds of millions of parameters
and billions of connections.
And this number is tiny compared
to today's neural network,
orders of magnitude
smaller than what we see
in today's computer science.
So with the help
of ImageNet and the
neural network algorithm,
the field of computer vision started
to see success in object recognition.
So we're able to categorize,
say, a picture of cat
or even find a cat in a
more natural everyday photo
or some other pictures, some other objects
such as teddy bears or girls or a boy
or even small objects like dog and kite.
And then a historical moment happened.
So for three years
after we build ImageNet,
we actually open-source this data set.
We believe this is an important
asset to our community.
Not only we open-sourced it,
we created an international challenge
to invite researchers around the world
to participate in the object
recognition challenge.
And we curated a particular task
called the ImageNet
object classification task
with a thousand object classes
and millions of images.
And then in 2012,
the winning algorithm of
the ImageNet challenge
is by Professor Jeff
Hinton and his student
called ImageNet classification
with deep convolutional neural networks.
With this work, and people
casually call it the AlexNet
because of the first author,
AlexNet cut the error rate,
or the generalization
error, as you all learned,
significantly compared to
the previous years' models.
And many people,
and maybe historians will
tell us in the future,
many people now consider
this moment and this work,
the ImageNet challenge and the Alex model,
the beginning of the
deep learning revolution.
But AlexNet is only the beginning.
There has been incredible progress
in the field of computer vision,
especially through these annual winners
of ImageNet challenge
in the following years.
And that trend didn't stop.
ImageNet challenge and the
deep learning revolution
took the world by a storm,
and we see the progress
of computer vision just accelerating.
And we're very honored
that ImageNet has been one
of the most cited work in the
history of computer science,
and also, it spilled over.
Computer vision, as well as AI,
was no longer a niche academic
discipline since the 2012.
It became a driving force of industry,
a transformative era
of some people call the
fourth industrial revolution
or the deep learning revolution,
and the field of computer vision,
if you look at some market research,
there is projected tens
of billions of dollars
of market available now
for computer vision,
and from Tel Aviv to Silicon Valley,
we're just continue to see the blossoming
and flourishing of
computer vision startups.
So back in the lab,
my students and I don't believe
that recognizing or the ability
to label object classes is the end
of our visual intelligence, right?
In fact, here's a simple example.
If I have two pictures
and they're both labeled
with the ImageNet
classifier person and llama,
you would think the second
picture is more or less
telling the same story
as the first picture.
But the truth is there's a
lot more in the pixel space.
In fact, this is a very different scene
from the left one.
And psychologists and
cognitive scientists again knew
about this before computer scientists.
This is a friend of mine
and one of my favorite
papers by Jeremy Wolfe,
partially because the
paper is only two pages.
He had conjectured
that just recognizing object is not enough
to understand and categorize a scene.
Relationships between
objects must be coded.
Indeed, there is rich
relationship within a scene
beyond just the identity of objects.
So my students and collaborators
and I actually propose this new work
called scene graph representation,
where we encode objects,
here in pink boxes,
the pairwise relationships,
here in green boxes,
as well as the attributes
that defines the objects,
here in purple boxes.
And you can see a simple picture
like this has a very rich
and dense visual scene representation.
And by creating a large data set
with this kind of annotated data,
we're able to do things like
predicting object relationships
in a scene, in this case,
such as person riding a horse
or person wearing a hat.
In fact, scene graph representation
is very compositional,
and because of this, we can take advantage
of the compositional nature and be able
to do something like zero shot learning,
which is we don't have to
train every relationship
with a ton of images.
In this case, our algorithm was able
to recognize horse wearing hat,
which is a rare event in life,
or person sitting on fire
hydrant, not so rare.
And in general, our algorithm at that time
using scene graph
representation performed better
than state-of-the-art
algorithm at that time.
Of course, calling out
or labeling relationships
is not the end of the story.
In fact, we humans can
actually tell a visual story
when we are presented with a scene.
So around a couple of years ago,
using deep learning algorithm,
my students and collaborators
and I had done a series
of work pushing the boundary
of visual recognition
beyond objects, beyond
relationship predictions
into storytelling and captioning.
In this case, we showed
this picture to a computer,
and the computers
automatically generate a story
such as a man riding a horse-drawn
carriage down the street.
And if we push it harder,
they can write denser captions
or even paragraph captions.
Even furthermore, the
visual world is not static,
and most of the world
is moving and dynamic.
So we push the scene graph representation
into spatial-temporal
space and we start to work
on recognizing multi-object,
multi-actor activities and relationships.
This is an example of an algorithm
recognizing not only ping-pong
or table tennis players,
but their movements and the relationship
between the table, the ball,
the referee, and so on.
So all this is to show you
that the field of computer
vision has really blossomed
and there are so many
interesting things to working.
Beyond my own lab, our field
has made tremendous progress
in 3D vision, in pose estimation,
in instance segmentation,
and in generative art of vision.
And this journey hasn't stopped.
We continue to see the explosion
of computer vision development.
So for this part, we have observed data,
compute, and neural network algorithms
ushered in the deep
learning revolution in AI.
But I'm a firm believer
that AI's development has
been and will always continue
to be inspired by brain science
and human cognitive science.
And here are the collaborators
and students and postdocs
who have contributed to the
work I mentioned earlier.
Now let's look beyond what humans can see.
I know what humans can see
as a inspiration of computer vision,
but can we build AI to
see what humans don't see?
Well, to start with,
we don't know everything
about the object world.
In fact, can you name
all the dinosaurs here?
Maybe if you have kids,
but even with kids,
I'm unable to name all the dinosaurs,
and there are tens of
thousands of bird species
and thousands of car,
I guess we don't call species, car types.
And so this is what we call
fine-grain object categorization,
and to be honest, most
humans, normal humans,
cannot recognize that level
of bird species or that many cars.
And this is where computer algorithm
have pushed the boundary
of human visual ability,
and we have in our lab, as
well as other people's lab,
created algorithms to do this kind
of thousands of bird species recognition.
And this is one of my favorite work
because we scrape the
Craigslist or Kelley Blue Book
to learn 2,800 types of cars
ever manufactured since the late,
I think, 1970s, and then we
take these car detectors,
we scanned Google Street View images
across 200 American cities,
and we learned about neighborhoods.
We learned about sociology.
We can correlate the recognition
of cars with census data
like neighborhood education level
or income or even voting patterns.
So computer vision,
just like human vision,
is a lens not only to
just see what the world is
but to see and understand who
we are and the human society.
So that was object categorization,
but I want to push you a little bit
because our human vision
system actually do have limits.
And this is a famous visual illusion test
that many of you know, the Stroop test,
and you know the words,
but can you read to yourself
the color of the words,
not the words itself?
So from left to right and top to bottom,
I would say red...
Oh, God. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
Red, orange, orange, green,
and it's hard, right?
And we feel bottlenecked
and there is a conflict.
And here's a related
visual illusion to show you
that we have limited
human attention resource.
So in a change blindness example,
I'm showing you two alternating pictures
and there's one change in
the alternating pictures.
Nod your head when you see the change.
Ooh, this is an IQ test.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so you didn't
nod as fast and as much
as Molly Potter's detecting the person.
So it's the jet engine.
Okay, let me do it again.
(audience chattering)
Right? A huge part, right?
And okay, so this is fun,
but the limitation of
visual attention is not fun
when it costs lives.
In fact, medical errors
are the third leading cause
of death in American healthcare system,
and we have many situations
in the medical scenario
that we need more visual attention.
For example, surgical instrument,
accounting for surgical instruments.
There are so many of
them during a surgery,
and to this day, it's
humans, nurses and doctors,
who have to tabulate and
count them during the process,
and it slows down the surgery
and sometimes causes errors.
So can we imagine computers to help?
If they can recognize 2,800 types of cars
or birds, can we account
for surgical instruments?
Here is a pilot study we did
in actual surgical rooms
at Stanford Hospital
where the computer vision algorithm
is automatically accounting
for all the sponges in the scene,
and we can imagine to take this further
and help the doctors and nurses.
So there is a lot more humans don't see
that we can ask computers to see.
But sometimes not seeing is more profound.
This is really one of my
favorite visual illusion,
and I'm just giving you
the answer right here.
I didn't even have time to test you.
So if you look at the top
image, square A and B,
don't you swear they're of
different grayscale values?
And then you copy this image
and put these two gray bars.
They're identical gray values.
Isn't that crazy?
Because of the context,
the prior knowledge of shape and lighting,
you have a different way
of processing this visual information.
For those of you who are
old enough, who are they?
(audience laughing)
Clinton and Gore, right?
Of course it's Clinton and Gore.
Really? Is it really Clinton and Gore?
Look hard. Now, it's
actually Clinton and Clinton.
But because of your prior knowledge,
the context, the hair and all this,
you see two different people.
You come with your own human visual bias.
And this is a fun example,
but bias is not fun.
Bias can be hurtful, bias can harm people
and then can particularly harm people
in underrepresented,
underserved community.
So computer scientist
and poet Joy Buolamwini
put this beautifully in a example
in a poem she wrote called
"AI, Ain't I A Woman?"
And this is to really raise the awareness
of AI algorithms, in this case,
facial recognition algorithms,
failing to recognize women
and people of color's faces.
So AI can amplify human bias,
especially if the data is biased
and has issues.
But the good news is there
is a growing body of work
that is seeking to address this.
I'm just showing you a few examples,
and there's a lot more happening now
and the awareness level is a lot higher.
So we talk about bias, seen bias,
but there is something even
more profound of not seeing,
and it's very important.
And consider the situations
when you don't want to be seen.
In fact, it is really important
to recognize privacy is
part of human dignity
and it's part of human rights,
and when we are creating
these powerful computer vision algorithms,
how do we address the issue of privacy?
I, for one, do not believe
technology is the only solution
to addressing human and societal issues,
but technology must raise to
the location and participate
in being a solution, not causing problems.
So there are actually a growing number
of technical approaches
to privacy computing
in computer vision.
Here I'm just listing a few,
whether it's face blurring,
dimensionality reduction, body masking,
federated learning,
homographic encryption.
Some of you might not
know all these words,
but for those of you who
come from computer science
and data science, these
are just some of the work
that my colleagues and I have worked in.
And I want to just show you one work.
It's actually not even my work.
It's mostly my collaborator
Juan Carlos Niebles
and his students.
This is a really fun work
of doing privacy-aware
computer vision computing.
They recognize that there is a need
for computer vision technology
to recognize human gestures
in many applications,
whether it's retail store
or safety or a garage or whatever.
But how do we do this in
a privacy-preserving way?
They devised a lens
that actually distorts the input.
So instead of seeing humans, it blurs.
The lens gives you images like this.
But it's not enough to
just have a blurred picture
because you still want to
recognize what's going on.
So they actually developed
a set of algorithm
that's coupled with this hardware
so that even when the
pictures is distorted,
the algorithm is still capable
of recognizing relevant human activities.
So this is a way to balance the need
to recognize what's going on
but to protect privacy
as much as possible.
Of course, all this is just ongoing work
and this is a long
journey, but in this part,
we talk about building AI to
see what humans don't see,
but what we really learned
is that bias, privacy,
these are the issues AI
can amplify or exacerbate,
many profound issues that
plagued humanity for ages.
So we as technologist,
along with other stakeholders, must commit
to study, forecast and guide AI's impact
on people and society in a
multidisciplinary approach.
And these are some of the
lead collaborator students
and postdocs who have contributed the work
I talked about in this section.
This brings us to the
last topic of the day.
It's building AI to see
what humans want to see.
Let's face it.
When we talk about AI today,
the most important concern,
one of the most important concerns
society has is the labor threat.
You know, when we are
building automating machines,
we're taking away human
jobs, be it truck drivers
or radiologists or factory workers,
and we see these kind of
headlines all the time.
I for one have worked in a industry
for the past 10 years that I see if not a,
I see a different angle, and
I see a equally important
or maybe even more
profoundly important problem
is actually the current labor shortage
in many of our industry,
such as healthcare.
By next year, that's,
like, two month from now,
America will be missing
one million nurses,
and our current nurses are overworked
and underpaid and over-exhausted.
And these are the issues,
the very human issues,
that we're facing.
So how do we balance the concern
for AI's labor threat, which is real
and we need to really think about it,
to many of the current
issues of labor shortage
or even unsafe work environments?
So we really believe,
and I really believe,
there is a verb we need to replace,
and it's the word replace itself.
AI should be augmenting
human capabilities,
not replacing human capabilities.
And I want to show you two lines of work
in this arguing for AI's augmentation.
One is backing healthcare.
I already give you a little
bit of a teaser early on
that medical error is a
leading cause of death,
one of the leading cause of death
in American healthcare system.
In fact, there are many
healthcare scenarios
where we don't have
enough human eyes to see,
to ensure quality, and to ensure safety.
So more than 10 years ago,
my colleagues in Stanford's medical school
and I came together and
start to really imagine,
can we, in this new wave
of machine learning,
deep learning revolution,
and smart sensors,
can we imagine that we
use these smart sensors
and ML algorithms to glean
health-critical insights
that are important for
patients and clinicians?
And this technology is what we call
ambient intelligence for healthcare.
A couple of years ago, we put our work,
10 years' work, in a "Nature" review.
I'm not going to get into
the details of this paper,
but I'll give you a a couple of nuggets
of what we talked about.
The first one is hand hygiene.
Hand hygiene practice,
proper hand hygiene practice,
is very important to reduce
hospital-acquired infection,
which causes tens of thousands of lives,
three times more than car
accidents on Americans' road,
and whether we're talking
about human auditors
or technology like RFID,
they are actually more or less ineffective
or too time- and labor-prohibitive.
So we piloted this project
at Stanford Hospital
where we put a smart sensor
on top of the gel dispenser,
the sanitization stations,
and these sensors capture depth images
that look like the blue videos.
So it's more or less
protecting the privacy
of our clinicians, but in the meantime,
our backend algorithms is running 24/7,
recognizing proper hand
hygiene activities.
Here, if you see a green box,
it means the clinician is
properly gelling his or her hand
before entering the patient
room, and the red box shows
that proper hand hygiene
movement did not happen.
Our algorithm performs
on par with ground truth,
is a lot better than one, three,
or even four human observers.
So we also worked in ICUs.
Patient mobility is linked
to improved recovery,
but how do we know a patient
is being moved properly,
both in terms of frequency
as well as other measures?
It's hard.
We're still resorting on human auditors,
and if you know anything about
the work of ICU clinicians,
you know they're overworked
and there are not enough hours
to even cover how much they need to do.
So again, we put these smart sensors
in Stanford Hospital
as well as a hospital in Utah
and start working with clinicians
on can we prototype
potential AI help here.
So here, you're seeing
that our AI algorithm is
recognizing four types
of activities or mobility
movements in the hospital,
getting out of bed, getting in bed,
getting out of chair,
and getting in chair.
And we're showing that our
algorithm is performing very well
against human-labeled ground truth.
Last but not the least,
there is a lot more potential
in using this kind of ambient
intelligence technology
in senior homes and aging in place
to predict and prevent unsafe events,
monitor patients with mild symptoms,
and manage chronic conditions
such as infection, mobility,
sleep patterns, and diet.
In fact, I pay particular
attention to this aging issue
because America is aging,
the world is aging,
and we're having a real
labor shortage of caretakers.
So can we go a step beyond
just passive smart sensors
to send alerts to doctors
and families when it comes to aging?
Here's a little bit of sci-fi.
Because of the decrease of,
you know, availability of caregivers,
can we imagine one day AI
in the forms of robots
can also help our seniors
or aging in place?
And here is not to replace humans,
human connection, human emotion.
Family is important.
But there is a lot of tasks
we can imagine robots to do.
And it's also, remember,
there is 18.4 billion hours
of home assistance from unpaid caregivers
that's not accounted in our current GDP.
And guess who it impacts the most?
Women and people of color.
So as a AI scientist,
I'm extremely excited to
imagine a robotic future
that can help people at home.
Well, don't get too excited too soon.
Here's where today's robots are.
We hear a lot of robots
in factory settings.
Those are very structured
and pre-programed settings.
If we put a robot in a
unstructured setting like this,
the poor guy can barely
put a box on a cart.
And this is...
I hope I didn't offend any
roboticists in the audience.
We know that there's a
long way to go in robotics.
In fact, most of robotic research today
is still more or less limited
to short-horizon tasks
such as placing something
or opening a drawer
or door or inserting a peg in a hole.
And moreover, if you
look at robotic research
and the papers we publish,
they're mostly done,
our experiments, in artificially
simple environments,
small-scale and anecdotal
experimenter-picked tasks
and setup, lacks standard
benchmark and metrics.
And if we want to connect this to the goal
of everyday robot, the real
world is a lot more complex,
dynamic, and uncertain,
has large variabilities,
interactive and social,
and has a lot of tasks.
So how do we close this gap?
Well, if we have learned anything
in the past decades of the
deep learning revolution,
we have learned that data and benchmark
has come a long way in
other related fields,
such as computer vision and
natural language processing.
In fact, with this kind of inspiration,
we ask ourself, can we get inspired
for a new north star for
robotic learning and embody AI?
And this is the last work I want
to present in this lecture today,
is a ecological robotic
learning environment
and a large and diverse set of activities
that is proposed by the
BEHAVIOR Project at Stanford,
which is a benchmark for
everyday household activities
in virtual interactive
ecological environments.
It's been so fun to work on this project
in the past three years,
and we have both cognitive psychologists
and roboticists and computer
scientists working together.
Before, we're talking about,
oh, wow, this is virtual world.
What are they talking about?
Let's just take a moment and think.
At the end of the day,
what kind of tasks are
we talking about here?
You want robot to help
everyday household activities.
What are the everyday
household activities?
Well, let's do a little bit
of a experiment right here.
I'm going to ask you about
some household activities
that you would like a
robot to help you with.
Just, like, nod or say
something if you like that.
What about cleaning the kitchen floor?
Okay, good.
Yeah. Good.
Shoveling snow in Connecticut?
Okay, good, good, good.
Folding laundry? Okay.
You know, I fold a lot of laundry at home.
I actually like that time.
But anyway, robot can do that.
Cooking breakfast?
I'm getting a little
bit of a pause from you.
Okay, this last one is the best.
Opening Christmas gifts?
(audience laughing)
Okay.
By the way, I don't know if
you notice, every single one
of the images are AI generated
here, not human artists, so.
Okay, so that's good.
So this is really important.
We are very enthusiastic technologist,
but before we even start our project,
let's focus on humans and
people and people's need.
So before we started BEHAVIOR Project,
we actually did a large-scale user study
with 1,400 participants
from Amazon Mechanical Turk
and screened and curated
2,000-plus everyday activities
that are proposed by government data
and ask people what would they,
how much would they benefit
if a robot did this for them?
Because it's important
to know what humans need.
And then we got the scores.
We ranked them.
As you just showed,
(audience laughing)
cleaning, we all want cleaning.
But people don't like robots
to open Christmas gift or throw darts.
I guess they're worry robot would win.
Or buy a ring.
I hope not. So, okay.
So if you put the top 1,000 tasks
that people prefer robots help,
they actually do cluster
into mostly cleaning tasks
or some simple cooking tasks
or some boring shopping tasks, and so...
So that's good.
So we decided we're going
to take the top-ranked
1,000 household activities
as the baseline or as the
activities we will work towards
for our robotic learning project.
But that's not enough.
In what environment?
We don't want to use
anecdotal, small-scale,
simple laboratory-made environment.
So we actually scanned 50
real-world environments
from apartments to restaurants to offices
to stores and use these as basis
for building our robotic training world,
and we also obtained
5,000 3D object models
across 1,200 object categories,
and these object asset models
cover 30-plus different properties from,
you know, temperature
changes to articulation
and deformability and so on.
Now with all these ingredients
together, we're ready to make
a unprecedented large-scale
simulation environment
for robotic learning.
Simulation environments are very critical.
In fact, they're fast,
they can be used to
transfer to real world,
they're safe, and they
are more reproducible
and we can work towards
a more fair data set
using simulation, and
there has been good work.
There has been a lot of
efforts in the field of AI
in creating simulation environments.
And these are some
of the state-of-the-art
simulation environments
by our colleagues in the world.
BEHAVIOR Project, we collaborated,
we partnered with NVIDIA's Omniverse team,
which is a commercial-grade
simulation environment,
and we aimed at creating
a realistic environment
to train robots both in physics,
perception, and interaction.
Here I'm showing you examples
of realistic physics.
You see thermal effects.
You see lighting and reflection effects.
You see fluid,
deformability, transparency.
We also did a user study on
the realism for perception.
We compared BEHAVIOR's environment
or simulation environment
against other simulation environment
and ask people to score
the perceptual realism
and BEHAVIOR came out pretty well.
We also try very hard to
reproduce the real physical,
the realism in physical interaction.
Here you're seeing robots
doing things with pretty complex materials
such as water, fluids,
or deformable materials.
So this is just a very messy, nerdy chart
that we put together to show you
the quantitative comparisons of BEHAVIOR
compared to other simulation environment
and how BEHAVIOR is more diverse,
more large scale and complex
in several important dimensions.
Of course, with the goal
of creating a new generation
of robotic algorithms
for these everyday household activities,
we want to start by asking the question,
how did today's algorithm do?
We picked three BEHAVIOR activities,
store decoration, collecting
trash, and cleaning table,
to benchmark against today's
state-of-the-art algorithm,
this is a little dense,
I promise this is the last
dense part of the talk,
where we use these three tasks
and we change different
conditions of the algorithm
to see how the
state-of-the-art algorithm do.
Let me just say that if we do not give
artificially privileged information
to today's state-of-the-art algorithms,
the performance is zero.
Well, that's actually encouraging,
at least that's what
I said to my students,
is that you want to be challenging
and this is where we can make progress.
But of course if we relax
and give some privileged
information, for example,
here, we give it what we
call action primitives,
which is, for those of
you coming from robotics,
you'll know this is a little more,
just pre-programed movements,
then the performance start to improve,
and if you add some
artificial memory to this,
it'll improve even more.
All this is to say,
this heavy chart is to say,
that BEHAVIOR is perhaps one
of the most challenging benchmark
in today's robotic learning
and we find it very exciting
that we have now this fertile playground
to train 1,000 household activities
for robotic learning algorithms.
And we're not stopping here.
We're also taking
simulation into real world
and creating a Sim2Real possibility.
At Stanford, we created
a real-world apartment
and also have a real-world
robot called Marvin
working with its own digital twin
in the simulation environment
so that we are simultaneously
training the virtual agent
as well as the physical agent.
Here's actually Marvin.
Marvin's very slow,
(audience laughing)
but Marvin is actually successfully going
to pick up this bottle with the goal
of sending this bottle to a trash bin.
So let's see if Marvin does that.
So please bear with me.
Marvin in this case
successfully will navigate
to the trash bin and place
the bottle inside, okay?
So but Marvin is not
successful in many, many times.
Sometimes, it navigate to the wrong table.
Sometimes, it just doesn't
pick up the bottle.
Sometimes, it didn't manage
to place the cup in the right place.
So I'm just showing you this to show you
we still have a long way
to go to get the, you know,
the cleaning kitchen
floor thing going for us.
And this is a teaser video to
show you our BEHAVIOR Project
and give you a little more sense
of the diversity of this environment.
All these are our simulation environments,
and with the video, you get
to appreciate a little more
of the complexity of BEHAVIOR,
complexity of the environments,
the large-scale things
from store to apartments
to restaurants, the kind
of different objects,
and of course the website of BEHAVIOR.
Okay, so we started by that per robot
and our goal is one day,
we'll create household robot.
And that's still a long journey,
but I'm very excited by BEHAVIOR
because it is born with the goal
of augmenting people,
not to replace people.
It's large scale and diverse
and it's striving
to be realistic and ecological.
So with all this work in building AI
to see and do what humans want
to see or want them to do,
we learn the value that AI must seek
to augment, not replace, our individual
and collective human
capabilities and wellbeing,
and there are a lot of
collaborator, students,
and postdocs who have contributed
to this part of the work.
So this brings us almost to
the closure of this lecture.
We've talked about three kinds of AI work
we have done in our lab.
What's most important is
after this 20-year journey
in building AI, we have
actually learned a lot
of human lessons, that the
development of AI must be guided
by the concern for its human impact,
that AI should strive to
augment and enhance humans,
not replace humans, and that
AI technologies must continue
to be inspired by human
intelligence and brain sciences.
And with these three
fundamental human values,
Stanford launched three years ago
the Human-Centered AI Institute
with the support of a
broad faculty leadership
across our, at that time, seven schools,
now we have eight schools,
from law to business to
medicine to humanities
to engineering and natural sciences.
And HAI is a very young institute.
I'll just highlight a couple
of things we have done,
mostly during pandemic, I guess.
We have launched the digital economy lab
to specifically put together economist
and computer scientist and technologist
to study the impact of
society, of labor market,
of our economy in this digital age.
We have launched a Center for
Research on Foundation Models.
All the news-generating AI you see today,
whether it's GPT-3 or this DALL-E art,
is by these large foundation models,
and they have profound
implication in our industry
as well as AI application,
both from ethical societal point of view
as well as from technology point of view.
So we have professors, faculty,
researchers coming together to study this.
We also pioneered a new way
of reviewing AI research grants
called Ethics and Society Review
inspired by the human subject IRB review
led by political scientist, a humanist,
and a computer scientist.
We also have education program
geared towards undergraduates
and graduate students
by embedding ethics in our
computer science classes.
But our education didn't stop
within the walls of Stanford.
We reached out beyond
the walls of Stanford
and start to extend AI education
to professional audiences
like business executives, journalists,
lawyers, and judges as
well as policy makers,
especially in Washington DC
but also at the state and local level.
And Stanford was very proud
to be leading the successful lobbying
of a bill called National
AI Research Resource,
and I believe Yale was part of the team,
and thank you for the successful effort.
So Biden administration launched
the National Artificial
Intelligence Research Resource
task force two years ago.
I'm very honored and humbled
to be one of the 12-people task force,
and in a few weeks we'll
be presenting to Congress
this new idea of how to
rejuvenate America's public
and higher education sectors capability
of innovating and education in AI.
So all in all, it has been an exhilarating
as well as humbling journey to create AI
to enable machines to see,
to realize the audacious ambition
that evolution have shown
us for 540 million years
to create intelligent machines in silicon.
But it's incredible that
along this technical journey,
we've learned more human lessons
and understand more human values
than machine-learned lessons,
and this is continue.
This is only in the
beginning of the journey,
and I want to thank, of
course, all my students
and collaborators and also sponsors
to support this research.
And thank you for listening.
(audience applauding)
(soft music)